Okay.
So now we're going to go back in time
to Sumeria and I'm going to show you how
this scenario creation
myth lays itself out.
And not only that,
I'm going to describe to you the direct
political implications of the new my
list,
a Sumerian creation,
Beth,
because the political implications of
that myth are well understood because the
political structure of Sumeria
was directly associated
with the structure of the
myth because the Sumerian emperor was
regarded as the earthly representative of
the highest God in the Mesopotamian
Pantheon whose name was Marduk.
So in so far as you were emperor,
the reason that you were emperor,
and this is what gave your
sovereignty legitimacy,
right?
Cause sovereignty has to have legitimacy,
otherwise there's constant revolutions.
What gave sovereignty legitimacy in
Mesopotamia was the identification of the
emperor with Marduk and that hat that
had certain implications for the emperor,
which we'll discuss in some detail.
The story starts like this.
You've got this drag tie a mat.
And timeout is a great primordial
beast who lives at the bottom of the
ocean and the ocean is water and water is
associated with the primal
element in archaic thinking.
And I told you there's
reasons for that already.
If you viewed the transformation of
deserts has a consequence of rain,
can understand why water would be
considered the element that gives life,
right?
That the element that
that brings life fourth.
And we know from an evolutionary
perspective that that's accurate.
And we know that we're 90%
water and so to consider water,
the primal element is
no trivial conclusion.
No,
no less than presuming that the
sun is the ultimate source of life,
the ultimate God,
because the sun is the ultimate source
of life as far as we're concerned on
earth,
right?
Cause it's the source of all our energy.
These aren't stupid concepts.
All right?
So timeout is this horrible creature
that lurks at the bottom of the primal
element.
All right?
Now she has a husband Appsu.
Now the massive detain me and creation
myth doesn't say much about Appsu.
We only know that he's the male con,
sort of the dragon of chaos.
And we know from reading other sources
of mythology that the male consort of the
dragon of chaos generally
represents either logos or culture.
So we're going to make the presupposition
in this particular case that the
husband of chaos is order or culture.
Okay.
And then the Mesopotamians
don't say much about that.
That that doesn't,
the development of the idea of apps
who are order or culture doesn't,
it doesn't take new force
until the ancient Egyptians.
We'll talk about them today too.
Okay,
so ty about naps who are locked into a
kind of sexual embrace according to the
Mesopotamian creation myth.
And what does that mean?
It kind of means two things.
It means that they're not
really distinguishable
because they're locked into
this embrace.
And it also means that they're up to
something creative because the act of
sexual congress in
mythology is most usefully,
is most frequently utilized,
has representation of something creative
or as representation of the probability
of some new form coming to be.
Right.
All right,
so abso in timeout are locked into this
embrace in a state that other creation
myths describe as egg.
Like the pre cosmo Gornick egg,
there are intermingling gives rise to
the initial state of being according to
the Sumerians.
And the initial state of being according
to the Sumerians is characterized by
the dominion of the elder gods.
These gods being none too bright,
make a tremendous amount
of rack doing things well.
What does that mean exactly?
Well,
it means something like this.
They make a lot of racket and
they cause a lot of trouble.
They make a lot of wind and all of the
racket and trouble and wind and activity
rouses tie amat.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means if you do things
and get in trouble,
it means even if you're
trying to solve problems,
you get into trouble because
the solution to a problem,
Chin tends to generate a
whole bunch of new problems,
right?
It's like the Hydra.
So what it means is that it's more or
less fated that any form of activity
whatsoever
is likely to produce the
threat of catastrophe.
And of course,
we're absolutely keenly aware of that
in the modern world because we are
possessed by this sense that
all of our frenetic activity,
all of our frenetic motivated activity
is producing alterations in the world
order such that nature itself is going
to be destroyed and eliminate us.